[Music]
an ex-cop who killed a man
over texting in a movie theater
has been acquitted of murder whoa
because that guy should have been
texting at the movie theater i agree to
shut
honestly bro if he wasn't an ex-cop and
he was just a regular citizen i'd still
let him off because when people are
texting and either in front of me when
they're next to you i want to grab their
[ __ ] phone and throw it out and be
like
do be like everybody else and do this
when you do this just try 30 second
timeout guys throwing out the phone
versus murdering them are two kind of
different things no you're wrong auntie
lee this is where you're wrong
this is what i do i turn my phone on the
brightest and then i put this on
why do you look like a blind chinese
accountant that's really good that's
good bart that guy deserves to be shot
do you think so all right i am okay with
him being dead yeah but it's so rude
though why do people do that it's so
mean don't do it don't don't be on your
phone when you're in the movie you guys
did not think the point of the story is
someone died it's like what do you mean
it's a killable offense i think i think
if you text on your phone in the movie
theater people get to ask you who are
you texting why are you interviewing
what are you saying to this person
then somebody else gets to ask like why
are you talking yeah and then the chain
of who gets shot is just infinite yeah
especially if it's a good movie yeah but
do people not know that in a dark room
right when you open up your phone
everybody behind you is now [ __ ]
because the eye like they they see the
right light paper closer to the screen
it's premium yeah i mean would be better
for those people that open up their
phones with the brightness on their
mouth breathers they're idiots they
don't think about other people they're
not considerate would you shoot a guy
who's in front of you with his phone on
and he's just watching an entirely
different movie no if he's watching a
different movie i understand but if he's
text expect the comic he's watching it
yeah if he's watching a different movie
then i'm like yeah he just doesn't like
this movie
he's just bored i get it what if he's
just recording the [ __ ] screen that's
different i would love it because i
usually use those sights so yeah it's
all good
steve's a big fan in hammer square he
turns around hi i'm malcolm footlocker
i'm like you're the guy i'm a huge fan
bro [ __ ] i love you man like i watched
the batman kyle i watched 30 minutes of
it but then i was like man i don't think
i know what's going on with this morning
i miss those bootleg dvds let's get some
details in here and see if any of your
opinions are changing the opinions don't
matter because obviously if he's texting
is that i'm sticking
double down on it no matter what
triple down dude and i'm to defend my
stance who do you think okay he shot him
that's what you think that's what i
think all right
he shot him i think old guy shot i think
old guy shot young guy that looks like
charles munger this guy texts a lot he
uses his phone loves his phone
this guy shot this guy yeah that guy was
flipping on a sidekick he was like
so this is this is our x-cop right here
by the way ryan what a host i mean i
think that maybe the dpi in their screen
like maybe the image is like this big oh
sorry
[ __ ] how do you do it do the thing do
the thing just hold it up here
he takes it further backwards he's like
okay so what do you guys think
this guy
[Laughter]
the hosting is unrivaled bro can you see
him he's over there he's making me and
anthony by the way a dancer and a
[ __ ] idiot
i thought there's a post guys
dancing no
so wait no
there's never going to be any post
reduction of them just putting the photo
on the [ __ ] screen in the edit though
i'm the dance that'll never happen oh
okay now i know that okay
i'll bring you guys a [ __ ] projector
for these kids
i don't want to do this
you guys [ __ ] see him you do that
every time me and joe me and joe are
always like what is it like what the
[ __ ] about because
i'm like i don't know for us though it's
great we have a great answer
we're like yeah no you guys are you
can't see [ __ ] i'm pandering for votes
here's what we do we go can we say that
i don't have a mac yeah i know
well i don't have a magazine do you want
to bring my own laptop
all right so this is the dude the old
guy shot the young dude but here's the
circumstance okay old guy's 79 years old
ex-cop
so young dude is texting on his phone
the old guy you know gives him some [ __ ]
says hey can you stop texting the young
guy goes what's your problem man the
movie hasn't even started it doesn't
matter so the old guy
the movie this is the double down sound
but the trailers are good exactly the
movie starts the experience starts the
minute you walk through the movie
theater i think that's why they designed
the whole hallway that way i'll say
and wait a second if you and if you're
expecting something important don't go
to the movies and if it's really if it's
an emergency keep it on vibrate and just
walk to the outside and then look at it
there's so many places to go but what
about the movie trivia part can you text
during the movie trivia part i think you
can nope yes you can and also until the
lights dip right before the movie after
the trailers and right before the movies
is where they show the no cell phone
thing that's when you turn it off yes i
think as soon as the lights dim you got
to put your phone away the lights really
dim when the movie starts even during
the trailers they leave it half lift so
you're cool when someone is lighting up
a cigarette in the middle of a movie
wait what nobody said that that's the
same [ __ ] totally different you wanna
smoke you go outside i can't smell it
so if you want to be on your cell phone
go outside kind of a stretch but i go to
the smoking section
just want to let you guys know bart's
for the murderer
i am too wait and see if it's justified
so what happens is uh he goes man the
movie he started yet and allegedly
throws a little bit of popcorn at the
old guy oh you can't throw a pocket old
guy leaves to go complain to the theater
manager he doesn't text the theater
manager no he doesn't
respect cinema he's an arclight member i
like him was this during the part where
the polar bears were drinking coca-cola
back in the 90s is during the part where
the movie seats turn into vines and
leaves and they all raise up
is this before the movie roller coaster
or goes by the popcorn and the candy
that's victorian right
wow that's another good one that was
good uh it's definitely before the movie
so then the guy goes to complain and
then returns
young guy
is still upset about the confrontation
gets in the old guy's face
they have a little bit of a yelling
thing and uh i guess
apparently knocks the popcorn out of the
old guy's hand so he went out to
complain but he was like i i gotta get
popcorn no the old guy wants to complain
yeah no so and then after he's like you
know what that ad did work on me let me
get the pocket since i'm out here cause
the experience started the minute you
walk in and he walked in and then he
goes you know what you owe a son of a
[ __ ] and then they slept and he goes
you just [ __ ] my [ __ ] popcorn now
you're gonna die well the part the part
that i sort of i'm like hey man because
like they in the testimony of the wife
who's there she's like oh he just told
him like like his movie has started he
didn't use any profanity against the old
guy nothing here's kindness but in the
video oh there's a video the young dude
grabs his popcorn out of his hand and
throws it at him yeah you can't do that
so the guy's 70 dude what are you doing
[ __ ] up man why are you picking on an
old guy
cause the old guy has to hurt his back
get picking up all his popcorn yeah one
by one so the old guy he's thinking the
stand your ground uh you know claws and
he's just like
i felt like my life was in danger
because he thought the guy was gonna
beat him up yeah so he pulled out a gun
shot in his chest and the bullet also
went through the wife's hand
whoa whoa and it hit her wedding ring
finger and then it's symbolism oh [ __ ]
but they're married at the same time
yeah the marriage yeah but honestly yeah
i did the movie theater uh
no her finger flew onto a guy's face and
the guy went down
no yeah that's really that's how it went
down so the guy was thinking the stand
your ground law would protect him and it
would never even have to go to court
what a brilliant guy honestly uh
and then the you know it still ended up
going to trial he wins the case because
you know rightfully he was he didn't
actually do a physical confrontation but
the young dude the guy was instigating
it the whole time this guy sucks yeah
and if you're an old guy and you're 79
and i mean it's hard to say like i mean
if you beat up an old guy he's probably
more likely going to die you couldn't
die from getting punched in the face
when you're like 80 years but this guy's
picking on him because he knows he's old
you think he would do that if the guy
was bart no way well it depends well
i'll tell you actually true story right
so i got to a movie like probably 45
minutes early because i actually misread
the time and this guy was there and and
i was on my phone just because like it's
45 minutes before the movie's even going
to start even i would get pissed at you
if the lights are on it's okay well no
the lights were on
yeah well i don't know if you really
know you said right when you walk in the
movie experience
and we were already walked in and so
this guy is like hey put your [ __ ]
phone away and let me just be a good
host right now and show you this guy
this is this guy
okay this is this guy
[Laughter]
and yeah he's like put your [ __ ]
phone away and i'm like absolutely not i
just want to be a good host right now
okay
and yeah he's like hey put your [ __ ]
phone away and i'm like absolutely not
absolute
movie's not even close to starting yet
and he's like you're ruining my
experience we're going to experience my
son i have a little son
i have a wife
you know and i was like hey [ __ ]
yourself and then yeah
let's take it outside
okay and then he and then he went
outside he broke the movie immersion and
then once he was outside i was able to
subdue him
you kicked his [ __ ] ass right yeah
yeah thank you thanks for showing us
because you know what he spent all his
time on the [ __ ] muscles but he
didn't work on the [ __ ] that really
matters yeah jude real [ __ ] taekwondo
we got tired fast
crap
[Music]
you